[MUSIC PLAYING]
MELANIE WARRICK: Hi,
and welcome to episode
number 147 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform podcast.
I'm Melanie Warrick,
and I'm here
with special co-hosts Willie
Brink and Nyalleng Moorosi.
Hello, Willie.
Hello, Nyalleng.
NYALLENG MOOROSI: Hi, Melanie.
WILLIE BRINK: Hi.
NYALLENG MOOROSI:
It's good to be here.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank
you for being here.
All right, I'm going to have
you both take a quick minute
and tell us a little
bit about who you are.
WILLIE BRINK: Thanks.
I'm Willie.
I am a lecturer at
Stellenbosch University.
This is, of course, also the
host for this year's Deep
Learning Indaba.
I have a passion for machine
learning, computer vision.
I have a passion for teaching,
and it is wonderful for me
to be here.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well,
I'm glad you're here.
Nyalleng?
NYALLENG MOOROSI: Yeah.
I'm Nyalleng Moorosi, as
Melanie has mentioned.
I recently joined
the Google AI team
for the group that's
going to be played.
That's going to be
in Accra, Ghana.
I'm very excited about that.
Before that, I was a researcher
at the Council for Scientific
and Industrial Research.
It's a very, very long name.
But it's a research lab here
in South Africa, government
funded, and also
partially industry.
I'm very, very excited to
be going to Accra, because I
can continue to do
machine learning
and continue living in Africa,
which is exactly where we
are here, at the Indaba.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
We are doing this recording,
and this episode specifically
is about Deep
Learning Indaba, where
we're going to showcase
a couple of interviews
that we captured
during this week.
Can you both take a
minute and just tell
the audience what Deep
Learning Indaba is about?
NYALLENG MOOROSI: Our line is
strengthening African machine
learning.
So it's always good
to start with that.
But I think that Deep Learning
Indaba has become strengthening
African machine learning.
But I think when we
started it we did not
know exactly how much it would.
And it has become a community
of sharing knowledge, of sharing
skill, of celebrating one
another, and, of course,
continual learning.
So it almost feels
like it's going
to be our yearly pilgrimage
where, from wherever we come
from, we go to wherever
everybody is and we collaborate
and we work together
and we just catch up
and we celebrate what we
did with the last year.
WILLIE BRINK: Yeah.
And I think also what
is very important
for us is to equip students and
academics from all over Africa
to come together, to meet
each other, to network.
But very importantly,
also, to go back
to their own
communities and carry
on this message of
strengthening machine learning.
And yeah, really just catching
up with the rest of the world.
Africa has enormous potential.
And I think it's a very
exciting time for all of us.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
Well as I mentioned,
we have some interviews
in this episode in particular.
We are going to be talking
with, and Willie, you
helped me with this.
We're talking with Yasin and we
are also talking with Vukosi.
And we're going to spend part
of that interview really talking
a little bit more about what
Deep Learning Indaba is about,
and some of the awards
that were given out.
And then the other part of
our interview that was covered
was with Andrea, who's
VC here in Africa.
And I know Nyalleng and
I just spoke with her
and had a great conversation.
So before we get
into our interviews,
as always, we
start out with some
of the cool things of the week
and the question of the week.
And we're going to wrap up with
a question that is pretty much,
what are some of our key
takeaways from the conference?
But as I mentioned,
we'd like to start out
with a cool thing of the week.
And we're going to do
a little variation off
of this, which is to help talk a
little bit about, sort of, what
are some of the highlights
that have been going on?
Not the key
takeaways, but things
that have been happening
during this conference.
What are some of the
great things that have
been going on, or activities?
Like, I know that we've
had a lot of speakers here.
WILLIE BRINK: Yeah.
So we've really had
an action-packed week.
Great speakers.
Nando de Freitas was
here and Moustapha Cisse.
And lots of others--
David Silver, Jeff Dean.
So it's a really, really
great list of speakers.
We also had poster sessions,
which were amazing,
all the students
presenting their own work.
Movie screenings of AlphaGo.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right
NYALLENG MOOROSI: Mhm.
WILLIE BRINK: There was a
Women in Machine Learning
event one evening, which
was really inspiring.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nyalleng,
you were speaking at that one,
as well.
NYALLENG MOOROSI: Yeah.
And it was very well attended.
It was one of our
biggest sessions.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And then there's
been students who are from
all over different countries
within Africa.
My understanding is
like 30 countries?
And the number of attendees
is around 550 attendees?
WILLIE BRINK: That's right.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Outside the WML event,
I think one of the
cool things that I
saw was when David
silver walked in
and somebody was sitting
there and looked over
and saw him and was like, oh, my
god, I just saw you in a movie.
He was so excited.
I thought that was
pretty fun to watch.
Any other little highlights
that come to mind?
NYALLENG MOOROSI: Yeah, I
think I also saw somebody
on a David Silver spotting.
He kind of lost his
mind a little bit.
The cool events.
Oh goodness, they
are just so many.
My coolest event was
the award sessions,
and the posters
are always really
rewarding and enlightening.
And half the time, I mean, you
just go there to just learn.
Meeting all of the
other people that
are actually machine learning.
And maybe that's actually
something to mention,
about the number of people
that have traveled from far--
other researchers
that have a jam
packed schedule that
traveled from far
to come spend the week with us.
And that's been very
exciting to see them, also.
MELANIE WARRICK: I agree.
Very much so.
Any posters that jump out?
NYALLENG MOOROSI: Oh.
Well, this is really
putting me on the spot,
because the one poster that
I do remember was actually
[? Steve ?]
[? Kuroon ?] and Herman.
Herman is also a colleague
who organized this.
And this poster will be at
NIPS, this year's NIPS poster.
And they have a closure they
have discovered about how
to add noise in a network.
So how much noise can
you add in a network
until you can't learn any more?
So actually you saturate the
network and you cannot any more
learn in a deep net.
And so they have these
closure properties
about how deep you can go and
how much noise you can add.
And that's really beautiful.
Because so much-- I mean that
just narrows the parameter
tuning such space.
I mean, this is work
that's being done
right here in Stellenbosch.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
Well, I think it's time
for us to go ahead and jump
into our interviews.
So let's go do that.
Today, I'm excited to have
with me Dr. Vukosi Marivate
and Yasin Musa Ayami, who are
both here at Deep Learning
Indaba, which is based in
Stellenbosch, South Africa,
for this edition of the
Deep Learning Indaba.
And with me also is Willie
Brink, who is helping
to be my special guest co-host.
So thank you all
for coming today.
YASIN MUSA AYAMI: Absolutely.
VUKOSI MARIVATE: Thank you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Now let
me go ahead and kick us off
like we usually do, which
is to have you tell us
a little bit about who you are.
So Vukosi, can you start?
VUKOSI MARIVATE: Thank
you for having me over.
My background mostly is in
kind of machine learning.
At the moment I am the
Chair of Data Science
and a senior lecturer at
the University of Pretoria.
Ticking through my
background, I was
interested in kind of
machine learning and AI
from a young age.
I ended up going to the
University of Witwatersrand
in Johannesburg doing electrical
engineering during undergrad,
and then a master's degree.
From there moved on to do a
PhD in computer science focused
on reinforcement learning in New
Jersey at Rutgers University.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
VUKOSI MARIVATE: When that
was kind of ending off,
I decided that I wanted
to go into data science,
because I was very interested in
some of the kind of it's being
dynamic, and looking at
different methods for lots
of different areas.
And then came back
to South Africa,
settled at the Council for
Scientific and Industrial
Research for about three
and 1/2 years or so,
working in data science.
And that's how also
I got kind of roped
in [INAUDIBLE] into the
Deep Learning Indaba.
MELANIE WARRICK: You got
roped in, they found you
and then they made
you come and do this.
Well, good to know.
And Yasin, can you
tell us a little
bit about your background?
YASIN MUSA AYAMI: My
name's Yasin Musa Ayami.
My background is in
software engineering.
I did my undergrad at the
Durban University of Technology,
and I graduated with a
[INAUDIBLE] cum laude.
And then later on I kind of
transitioned to the field
of AI.
My area of research
was computer vision.
So besides that, I'm also a
certified Oracle associate.
I'm also the co-founder
and CTO at TsogoloTech.
And yeah, my vision has always
been to kind of leverage tech
for social good.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
That's great.
Well, so the reason why
we're doing this recording
specifically is
because we wanted
to touch on two things
that are playing out.
One, you know, Deep Learning
Indaba and what it's about.
As well as the
Maathai Award that
is at Deep Learning
Indaba, which Yasin,
I know you had won.
We were actually just
talking about it today.
So let me go ahead and
kick off with, first,
like what is Deep
Learning Indaba?
Tell us a little bit about
what is this conference?
Where did it come from?
What do you know about it?
Why are you doing this, Vukosi?
And Willie.
VUKOSI MARIVATE: Yeah, so being
facetious about being roped in.
It was a good group of
friends and acquaintances
who came together
after one-- like,
I guess a number
of iterations of,
if you went in to some of
the big machine learning
and kind of data science
or data mining conferences,
seeing the lack of participation
from the African continent is
something that was,
I think, concerning.
And not more only just do people
have papers there, really.
But on, I think, from my
view, that those people
are missing out.
There's a lot that's
going on the continent.
There's a lot of very
interesting areas
that people are working on
that might not be seen maybe
if you're sitting in Google
or Microsoft in Europe
or in the US, that you
might not think about,
but that people are
trying to resolve.
So through a number
of conversations,
I knew a lot of local
organizers personally before.
And we started talking
about this and saying,
can we do something
in terms of trying
to grow machine learning and
its visibility on the continent?
Not that it's not there.
But if we could find a way
to bring people together,
come share their work, their
expertise, build their network,
and get this to kind of snowball
into something that's going
to be much bigger than just us.
So the Indaba [INAUDIBLE]
really encompasses
that, in that we're trying
to strengthen African machine
learning.
And by doing that, it's
building the community in itself
as one way of doing that.
Learning from each other,
offering each other's skills
to the community,
and seeing where
this is going to get us in
kind of a couple of years.
So even though this
is the second year,
this is still like
the beginning.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And you mentioned
that it's the second year,
last year being the first year.
Where was last year,
and how many people?
VUKOSI MARIVATE: Last
year was at the University
of Witwatersrand.
That university has its
home in Johannesburg.
And that was about
330 people from 22
different African countries.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
And this year it's around
550, is my understanding.
VUKOSI MARIVATE: Yeah.
550, as a target.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Well, when you
mentioned community,
I know we were talking actually
before we started recording
about how there's all
these Deep Learning IndabaX
events and community
building activities
that have been happening
throughout different countries
within Africa.
And so Yasin, I know you
are one of the organizers.
And specifically you
organized one in Zambia.
And when was that
that you organized it?
YASIN MUSA AYAMI: On
the 24th of March.
MELANIE WARRICK: OK.
And what was that like, in terms
of organizing the event there?
YASIN MUSA AYAMI: It
was a bit challenging,
you know, organizing
the IndabaX in Zambia.
Because one was the
issue of resources.
Having spent most of my time
in South Africa and organizing
things here, I was
assuming that it was going
to be the same that I did.
But when I got
there, I literally
had to pay for everything,
including venues, computers
and things like that.
So when we kind of
advertised for people
to kind of register
for the IndabaX,
we received a number
of applications.
But sadly, due to the
number of resources,
we could only
accommodate a few in it.
We only accommodated
about 60 participants.
And I had participants
[INAUDIBLE]
when we could not
accommodate them.
And mostly, if you look at the
expenses that were incurred,
you know, there's expenses
that were not supposed
to be incurred, in a way.
Because you're
looking at something
that you want to
empower people, you
want to give
knowledge to people,
you want to produce a
cohort of youth that
are technologically empowered.
So we're trying to associate
it to universities.
But when we approached
universities,
they were not open to the idea,
because they were looking at it
from a marketing perspective.
I mean, they were talking
about issues to do with, OK,
if you want to
partner with us, come
with at least 50 participants.
So that, in a way, was
difficult from our end.
Because we couldn't like
provide for the 150 people.
So we ended up like resorting to
having other venues, which was
not supposed to be the case.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, what
went well for the event?
YASIN MUSA AYAMI:
OK, so what went
well is the positive
feedback we got from people.
So people now are
saying, let's make
this an annual thing, whether
Deep Learning Indaba is in
or Deep Learning
Indaba is not in.
So we've got also
some good responses
from corporate people,
and we're hoping that more
would buy into the idea.
So like we've had people,
you know, coming to us
and saying, OK, why you
never reached out to us?
And we're like, no.
The people that you've
employed to kind of let
us have access to you were
denying us access to you.
Or sometimes we'd send
emails, but you're not
responding to our emails.
But at least now we've
kind of established
contact with these
people, and be
able to contact them directly.
So going forward, I think
the subsequent Indabas
will be bigger and
better, and obviously
will have more and more
people coming on board.
So the next Indaba, we're
hoping to have at least maybe
150 or more people.
And yeah.
So arising from the
Deep Learning Indaba,
there are some
monthly tutorials that
aim at increasing the
number of people that are
in this area of data science.
And yeah, so we're hoping,
that as the population
grows of people in data
science, then certain issues--
you can have a number
of people working
on various issues that are
being affected in the country.
MELANIE WARRICK:
What's going well?
And what are some
of the challenges
that you've seen, Vukosi,
from working on Deep Learning
Indaba?
VUKOSI MARIVATE: The biggest
challenge is always demand.
MELANIE WARRICK: Very common
to what Yasin's saying, yeah.
VUKOSI MARIVATE:
Yeah, starting off
I think, maybe going back to
the beginning of the Indaba,
we had envisioned I think
50 even in the first year?
MELANIE WARRICK: Wow.
VUKOSI MARIVATE: That was
where we were planning for,
and we ended up getting
like 700 applications.
And by then I think
we were thinking,
OK, let's just make it 200.
So by the time 700 applications
came in, it was, we can do 200.
We need to increase this
as much as possible.
So it's something that we
have to come to terms with.
And again, it's
this thing of saying
that things are happening.
People are wanting to
do more in this area.
The amount of times you talk
to professionals, students,
even academics, who
come up and say, look,
yeah, I'm doing y or x, but
I'm actually very interested
in machine learning and
artificial intelligence
because I have this
idea, and I think
if I can just grasp
the methods, I
will be able to actually
do something with it.
That's what the Indaba is for.
And the kind of knock
ons are still something
that I think we're still
having a very hard time being
able to quantify.
So just from what Yasini
is saying, of saying,
now you have monthly events.
And every time you meet
the IndabaX organizers,
there is always a story
about this other thing
that we actually started
doing afterwards.
And being able to empower them
to continue into their journeys
is also important.
Because you know, we as
the main Indaba organizers,
can only do so much.
You know, you know you
can only cover so many.
So even with the
first year only having
330 being at the main
event in Johannesburg,
the IndabaXs actually then
had a total over 1,000
over that March
and April period.
So you can see that
that's a bigger
factor in terms of doing that.
And yes, it does
bring in more people--
more demand, again, to
us, because then people
want to come for the--
MELANIE WARRICK: But that's
a good problem, right?
VUKOSI MARIVATE: Yeah, that
is a good problem there.
And yes, for us we try
to keep the mission
being the main thing,
the strengthening
of African machine
learning as being what
we want people to sign on for.
So in working to get sponsors
or get partners maybe, you know,
we want them to buy
into that mission.
And if it's not the thing
that they want to do,
it's like-- you
know, we understand.
But it's this cornerstone
that we need to keep,
because that's why
people come here.
They set over six days
and with little sleep
going through a lot of
content, talking to each other.
Like, you get amazed at kind
of some of the connections that
are made.
MELANIE WARRICK: A
significant amount of contact
that's definitely being
covered at this conference,
so I can understand that.
And the fact that there's
monthly tutorials that
are also being produced is
also kind of incredible.
And frankly, I
heard someone saying
how they were amazed at how
much people are just engaged.
It's so wonderful to see how
much engagement there is,
how much excitement there is
about what's being shared.
So thank you.
Well, OK.
So let's get into
the fact that there's
two awards that were given
out, and some honorable
mentions in relation
to those award.
And I know the Maathai Award
in particular was given out,
and it was really to recognize
along the lines of, you know,
even people who are
individuals, especially,
can have large impacts
in the world around them,
especially in the ways
that they approach problems
that they're solving.
Is that doing it pseudo justice?
I know it's probably not
doing it full justice.
But could you expand a little
bit more on that, Vukosi?
VUKOSI MARIVATE: It was
a prize to recognize
innovation using
machine learning
AI across the continent.
So whether there was a
group or an individual,
it didn't matter, but
we wanted to see what
people were doing out there.
I think Yasini completely
embodies this, where you go off
and you have this societal
challenge that is out there.
And you think about, what
is an approach that I could
use to try and tackle this?
Right?
And then you go
backwards and then
you find something
that's kind of tangible.
And then you say, OK, I
need to now use this tool
and learn and see how I
can innovate around it
to be able to then kind of
get people where they are.
As opposed to going
like, you know, hey,
I've got this hammer,
I need to hit nails.
And I'm looking out for nails.
And I think, yeah, that's what
the Maathai Award is about.
MELANIE WARRICK: So let's
talk about what you're
working on at TsogoloTech.
YASIN MUSA AYAMI:
Yeah, TsogoloTech.
OK, so TsogoloTech
is a tech startup
that aims at making use of
state of the art technology
to kind of contribute
toward solving
these socioeconomic problems
that we're currently facing.
So among them is the issues
of cholera, the issues
with financial inclusion.
Like underserved
communities, how
can we include them in the
formal financial sector?
What made me win the
Maathai Impact Award
was the app that
we created, called
Tukuka app, which aims at
automating transactions.
What happens is, women
in underdeveloped areas
have resorted to coming
up with village banks.
So village banks, this is
a kind of a system which
enables people that are
living in the same area
to contribute money.
Then from that money
that they contribute,
then they are able to lend
it out amongst themselves.
And then they're able
to repay back interest.
So what was happening is, of
course, that was a good idea.
But the challenge
was the transactions
that occurred during this
process were done on paper.
So we kind of thought that if we
kind of automate this process,
and once we automate
this process,
then we will have data--
data we can use for many things.
Among the things that
can be done with this
data is approach banks.
Because you find that these
areas maybe do not have a bank.
So you can go to a
bank and say, OK,
see these people are
making x amount of savings.
And I think these people need a
branch or something like that.
Or again, since there's this
issue of cryptocurrency,
the blockchain, that is
making waves on the internet,
I mean, how can we
innovators come up
with ways in which we can use
these technologies to kind
of aid these people in
managing their transactions?
So that's what this
app was all about.
And we envisage to find
of, by 2019, to reach out
to about 22,000 women.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's awesome.
Well, why women?
YASIN MUSA AYAMI:
OK, well, if you
look at the stats, financial
inclusion stats in Zambia,
about 41% of adults are
financially excluded,
and majority of which are women.
And most of these
are rural dwellers.
So that's the reason why are we
mostly looking at these people.
Because these are people who
may be going to door to door,
selling items, farming.
So the little that
they are making,
if it's not properly
managed, then they
end up having nothing.
So I think that's what kind of
made us focus mainly on women.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's wonderful.
And the app itself, can you
tell us a little bit about that
and how it functions or
what kind of technology
are you using?
YASIN MUSA AYAMI: OK.
So we created a
prototype, a mobile app.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It's called Tukuku?
YASIN MUSA AYAMI: Tukuka--
MELANIE WARRICK: Tukukaka.
YASIN MUSA AYAMI:
--yeah, so which
enabled these people
to kind of enter
their transactions on this app.
And then obviously there
was some backend application
that was storing the data.
So now what we observed is the
literacy levels are very low.
Also the financial literacy
levels are also low.
So you find that
there were issues
in terms of recording
these transactions.
And you find that somebody
cannot write or record
the transactions, so they had
maybe to depend on somebody
to record for them transactions.
Consequently,
somebody might end up
maybe recording wrong
transactions or one is not
able to track their
own transactions.
So if we kind of
automate this process,
we thought this could
somehow, you know,
knock out some of these issues.
So that's the reason
why we created that app.
But since these people
have low literacy levels,
it's been difficult to kind
of make use of the app.
And looking at the
internet levels,
the penetration of
it's still not that much.
So we're thinking of now
integrating the SMS system.
So where we want to
use USSD for them
to record these
transactions instead
of using the mobile app.
Then subsequently, after
we've got these transactions
automated, we're looking at
making use of state-of-the-art
machine learning, deep learning
to kind of help these people
view their credit profile.
Because if you go to a
bank, obviously, they
need some form of collateral
for you to get a loan.
And now these are people that
do not have access to banks.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
YASIN MUSA AYAMI:
And of course, many
do not have access to loans.
Just as an example, I
don't know if you've
been following the news.
We've had like three infernos
in the last couple of years,
which happened, I
think, two months ago.
[INAUDIBLE] COMESA market,
which houses people
from the COMESA region.
So you've got people from
Tanzania, people from Malawi,
you've got people from Zimbabwe.
So there was an inferno there,
and people lost goods worth--
MELANIE WARRICK: But
they lost their currency.
YASIN MUSA AYAMI: Yes, yes, yes.
So you find that that was their
only source of livelihood,
and they couldn't
be compensated.
They were looking up to
the government to kind
of compensate them, but you
know, the government couldn't.
And so these people have just
resorted to staying at home.
So Zambia being a country,
a third world country,
that is striving
to fight poverty,
I don't think it's
possible to fight poverty
if that's the case.
So we're hoping that if
the app is successful,
then we can help them
view their credit profile
and then,
subsequently, link them
maybe to formal
financial institutions,
like the banks, where they
may be able to access loans.
But of course, you know,
with village banks,
they're able to get loans.
But it's only a limited
amount of money,
because the contributions
is maybe $1 or $2.
So if somebody wants a
loan of maybe $1,000,
so you find that maybe the
group cannot sustain that.
The amount of savings that
they've got cannot service
that.
So if we build the credit
profile, then subsequently,
these people will be able to
kind of go approach the banks,
and then the banks
will be able maybe
to give these people loans.
So that's what we're aiming at.
And obviously there's
been a lot of research
that's been going on.
I mean attending the Indaba,
we're talk about 550,
the majority of
which [INAUDIBLE]..
So if you carry out
a random survey,
I don't think
there's maybe anybody
that's maybe working in the
financial inclusion space.
Or, to be specific, somebody
working on this village app
thing.
One of the reasons could
be the issue of data.
So we're hoping that, if
we generate this data,
we can then push
it to the public,
so people can make use of it
and then do some research.
Of course, we are
cognizant of the fact
that yes, there are
issues of ethics
that have to be considered.
So that's where we
are heading towards.
MELANIE WARRICK: So in
terms of the data itself,
you said you're
storing it currently.
What are you storing it on?
YASIN MUSA AYAMI: Well,
we're just storing it online.
We got a backend application
that is storing the data.
And of course, we are going to
use some APIs to kind of expose
the data if we want to use
it for machine learning
or something like that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Is it an
app that exists currently or?
YASIN MUSA AYAMI:
It's a prototype.
MELANIE WARRICK: Prototype, ah.
YASIN MUSA AYAMI: But it's
not yet on the market.
I mean, we're just
testing it out.
MELANIE WARRICK: Got it.
What are you prototyping it on?
Is it on like an
iOS or an Android?
YASIN MUSA AYAMI: Yes.
It is an iOS app.
We used some Microsoft tools.
I don't know if I'm
allowed to of market
other people's product.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's OK.
Yes, you can totally talk about
what other programs you used.
What are some of the ones that
you used on the Microsoft side?
YASIN MUSA AYAMI: I
was using Submarine.
Submarine enables you to
create cross-platform app.
OK, so with TsogoloTech
we don't necessarily
have in-house developers.
So mostly it's people
who have got time
and are willing to spend their
time working on social issues.
So it was one of my
friends, [? Janin, ?]
that was actually
working on the app.
We're actually corroborating.
I was doing minor
changes here and there,
but she did most of the work.
And with me, I was focused
on creating the backend
and obviously providing
her with an API that
would enable her to consume
for the app functionality.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
What are your future plans?
YASIN MUSA AYAMI:
My future plans
are to tackle as many
problems as possible.
Of course, offline,
we're talking
about the issue of cholera.
In the next three
months, there will
be another disaster I
presume, because there's
nothing that has been done from
the last time we encountered
this problem, the
issue of cholera.
So I'm trying to also kind of
see if we can tap into that
also, to see how we can
use existing data to reduce
the number of cases
that are recorded
and subsequently reduce
the numbers of deaths
that are recorded.
So those are some of the plans.
And yeah.
Also, to get as many local
developers as possible.
Because, I don't know.
I don't see it appropriate
for local developers
to kind of contribute to
offshore projects on GitHub
when we've got a
lot of issues that
have to be tackled in-house.
At Tsogolo we are
fortunate to kind of
have two groups of people.
One are engineers,
and others are
people that are working
on developmental work.
So these people working
on developmental work
kind of point us to areas
which need attention.
They tell us, OK, this, I
think this needs a problem.
So we engage the engineers
to kind of come up
with a tech solution that
can tackle this problem.
So we're hoping to have as many
local developers as possible
helping towards
achieving this goal.
MELANIE WARRICK: Do
you accept support
from external developers
that are not-- you know,
is that something
that you do currently
or that you want to do?
YASIN MUSA AYAMI: Well,
I think it's something
that, yeah, we'd want to do.
You know, collaborate
with external developers.
I mean, on Saturday
I'm actually leaving--
I told you I'm
leaving for Germany.
So with Germany, we're
going for a sit-in program
but it's more like an
incubation program.
So they kind of walk
you through the stages
of developing a product
and, of course, releasing it
to the public.
And of course, ways you
can manage that product.
So it's basically
aimed at startups.
And then seeing how they
can sustain the startup.
Because what happens is
you've got a startup that
is in existence for a
few months to years,
then it just disappears.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
Well, that's great about the
startup incubator in Germany.
And then, in terms of, if
somebody is listening to this
and they want to
help or they want
to participate in terms
of what you're building,
how would they do that?
YASIN MUSA AYAMI: So,
they can reach out to us.
MELANIE WARRICK:
We'll definitely
have your contact information.
We'll get that from you and
put that on our show notes.
YASIN MUSA AYAMI: Yes,
they can reach out to us.
Because the issue is we've
not been able to do much,
because we're just
relying on people
that are already working.
So they can only work on certain
projects when they are free.
If we could have, you know,
proper funding to kind of
have in-house maybe data
scientists, software engineers,
we will be able to work on
these problems more quickly,
you know.
Because the issue with
tech is like they say,
the only thing with technology
that does not change
is that it's always changing.
Maybe today I might
be talking about,
OK, we want to make use of
cryptocurrencies and blockchain
to tackle this issue
of financial inclusion.
Tomorrow there's something else.
So once I'm still
working on this,
then it becomes
in a way obsolete.
So I just have to stop,
because I feel demotivated.
Our goal is to come up with
ways in which we can quickly
work on these problems and then
maybe deploy it to the public.
And then see if challenges
that people are facing,
analyzing a way that
is solving the problem
that we're trying to solve.
Then also trying to
identify ways in which we
can improve on the product.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That sounds great.
Well, thank you.
Before we wrap up, what I
want to touch on is, you know,
what are some of the
key things that you're
taking away from the Deep
Learning Indaba for this week?
What are some things
that you've experienced
so far that have been really
valuable for you in terms
of what you've seen?
VUKOSI MARIVATE: Just also
touching on what Yasini has
been talking about, in my
general knowledge at University
of Pretoria starting out,
especially in data science,
is to do data science that
comes from social [INAUDIBLE]----
so coming from social
impact as a space.
So I'll be very happy
to like, you know,
have more conversations about
how do we go from that data,
find ways to release
it in the proper way,
or release it just
to be able to use.
And for us, a place like
the University of Pretoria,
being able to work with
students to actually build
on the research in that space.
Because yes, in one
part, there is data.
The other is experts
like Yasini over there.
And this also has
permeated the Indaba.
If you go in and
you see the posters
and you see what people
are actually presenting
and the things that
they're working on,
you kind of start
seeing threads of,
oh, this could
turn into something
bigger if you could
get, like, you know,
one, two, three,
four people together
from these different countries.
You know, we shouldn't look
at our borders and say,
that's where we end.
I think the Indaba is trying
to reduce that distance
and allow people to
be able to work across
and be able to mentor
other students,
mentors professionals
across these borders.
So I'm hoping that is a
thing that is going to go on.
I've seen examples of people
doing this after meeting,
especially at our meeting.
Not to, like you Yasini
was saying, advertising--
at Data Science Africa
I did meet people
last year, as a part of
my trying to cover as much
of the continent as possible
and bring people in,
just like we met.
MELANIE WARRICK: We did, I know.
And I was saying
this offline, that I
know about this conference
because of you, Vukosi,
because you were at a
conference that I was at
and you spoke about it.
And I immediately was like,
how do I get involved?
VUKOSI MARIVATE: So, exactly.
I was at Data Science Africa
trying to talk about the story,
show about my research, but also
that we're having the Indaba.
That led to, we have one of
our co-organizers, Kathleen,
who actually I met at
Data Science Africa.
I had a gentleman that I got to
then mentor this year working
on disease modeling in Malawi--
just having like a
few Skype meetings.
It's not this-- like,
people think oh,
mentoring means you're
spending half your--
MELANIE WARRICK: Years
and hours and all day.
VUKOSI MARIVATE: Yeah,
I wasn't doing that.
But then trying to reduce that
and being able to end up--
I've seen people like
Benjamin Grossman
doing kind of the same thing.
WILLIE BRINK: Yeah,
and maybe I can just
add that Africa as a continent
has so many problems that
are unique to the continent.
And it is very important
for us to equip our students
to be able to deal
with these problems.
And hopefully the
Indaba also goes
some way towards that goal.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
And I know that the sessions
that are being held right now
are being recorded, and
that will be released.
Do you guys know when
that's going to be released?
WILLIE BRINK: We were hoping
for very soon after the Indaba.
Maybe over the weekend
or early next week.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great,
and-- oh, and you
were going to say
something else?
VUKOSI MARIVATE: It
also, again, speaks
to this ethos of sharing.
Whether somebody is
at the Indaba or not,
should get as much of
the content as possible.
So there's a lot
of work that has
gone into the practical
sessions, and all of that
is on GitHub already.
And people can go
interact with it, I think.
MELANIE WARRICK: We'll
get the links for it
and put those up there.
VUKOSI MARIVATE:
I keep on saying,
we're trying to
manufacture abundance.
It's not about
reducing access, right?
It's increasing it, so making
sure that there's videos.
There's the practical sessions,
and the practical sessions also
all that content is available.
Yes, sometimes it does go down.
When it goes down, it's
because it's being improved.
It's not that we're removing it.
And that's what
happened, we know,
we switched off last
year's practicals.
We then start getting messages
of people asking you, please,
can we have access?
We were actually just
waiting for the switchover
to this year's practicals,
which are much better.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, I've
heard wonderful commentary
in people seeing the
practicals and having
wonderful experiences with them.
And next year, Deep Learning
Indaba is going to be in Kenya.
Do you know where?
YASIN MUSA AYAMI: Kenyatta
University in Nairobi, Kenya.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
VUKOSI MARIVATE: The
good news is also
that we are again trying to
increase the numbers quite
substantially.
So please look out for
the calls for applications
for next year's edition.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Anything else that you wanted
to talk about or make sure
we cover before we go?
YASIN MUSA AYAMI:
So I just wanted
to add on what we and
Vukosi were talking about.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, please.
YASIN MUSA AYAMI: Issues
to do with the problems
that we're facing
as a continent.
So one problem that
we're facing as Africans
is, when we get people like
Google, when they approach us,
so we leave Africa and
then go stay in Europe.
In terms of making progress,
in a way, we're regressing.
So we're not making any
changes to whatever problems
that we're facing.
So I think of late,
yes, we've had
issues where we've
had to hire experts
from Europe to come and solve
our problems here in Africa.
And of course, I don't know
for lack of [INAUDIBLE]
I would say I know some more.
And to say that, OK, we've got--
there's unemployment in Africa.
On the other hand,
you're outsourcing people
to work for your people.
So I think right now, since
AI is still in its infancy,
if we can get as much people as
possible into this space of AI,
so that instead of outsourcing
people from Europe to come
and solve our issues, I think
we should be the better people
to kind of tackle our issues.
I think we understand
them better.
Like we all know, you know,
you cannot compare an original
vision to a translated vision.
So I'd like to
recommend the ways
that these guys like
[? Shakir ?] and other guys
that are working in London.
You know, of course
they got jobs there,
but they did not forget
about this African continent.
And of course, decided to come
up with Deep Learning Indaba,
and of course sacrificing
their time and effort in trying
to make this thing a success.
From these 550
participants, you can just
imagine how many more
people are going to benefit.
Obviously, people are going
back to their communities
with feedback.
And of course, the
Deep Learning IndabaXs,
I think it was in 13
countries, the previous ones.
So we've got about
22 African countries.
So I'm hoping that in 22
African countries plus
there will be some
sort of an IndabaX.
And then if the IndabaX is
yearly held around March,
if we can have like, total
participants for these IndabaX
even more than 100,000.
So I think it will be
a great plus to meet.
So like we will just
say that, OK, they
are trying to increase
the number of people
that are going to participate
in the Deep Learning Indaba.
So people doing
this certainly need
to attend the Deep Learning
Indaba, the main one.
But through these small
Deep Learning IndabaXs,
because of course there's
issues of funding.
So you have to fly people from
Cameroon, people from Egypt,
to come and attend Indaba.
So that, in a way,
would kind of limit you
in terms of doing
certain things.
So if we can identify
people that we
can train promptly
and of course run
these Indabas in
respective countries,
I think that would
be more effective.
So as I was organizing
the Deep Learning IndabaX,
one of the issues that
I faced was the issues
to do with speakers.
There were few speakers I knew
of that could deliver talks
at the Deep Learning IndabaX,
one of which is [INAUDIBLE]..
He was invited to come and do
sessions and much tutorials.
So if we can also beat
capacity in that area
to increase the number
of people that can also
flow this content to
other people, I think also
would be heading towards
the right direction.
So I don't know if we can have
Indaba just sort of designed
to train people, to become
sort of a trainer of trainers.
Which, yes, you know, when
you talk about IndabaX Zambia,
we know exactly that.
OK, there's x, y and z.
Because one is having
an IndabaX in Zambia.
But two is also
having people who
are able to deliver content to
these participants and then,
of course, having these
participants benefit
from the tutorials that will
be given by these participants.
MELANIE WARRICK: This is great.
And thank you.
And anything else
that you guys wanted
to touch on before we go?
VUKOSI MARIVATE: The
thing I've been parroting
over the last few days
just over and over again
is going to be that, yes,
we are getting to a point
where we have to think
about, how do we grow?
Scaling is definitely on
our minds as organizers,
and trying to figure
out what's the best way.
At the same time, we
aren't ignorant of the fact
of a lot of other initiatives
that have been kicked off
or have kicked off a
little bit earlier than us
or have kicked off
after we have started.
Even here in South
Africa, there's
a lot going on in this
week in this area in terms
of machine learning.
So just think about
the continent.
So how do we come together
as this wider community?
MELANIE WARRICK:
And be stronger.
VUKOSI MARIVATE: And
be stronger, yes.
It's not about us.
That's a thing I'll keep
saying to my co-organizers,
that it's not about us.
It's going to be
about the community.
And to do this, we're going to
have to come together and come
up with a strategy on how we
bring in all these resources
that we have, that might
be minor in the bigger
scheme of things,
but we still have
to optimize them
to deliver well.
And through this, if we
can connect them together,
find ways for people to
move in and around them,
it builds a much better,
stronger community of practice.
And right now there's
International Data Week
that will be happening
in Botswana in November.
I am hosting a session there
on data for good, specifically
to try and find even more
people who work in it.
Like, you know, creating
these honeypots of,
people will submit some
abstract and then you'll go in
and say, oh, we didn't even
know that people in your area
are doing this.
So maybe you should
also come in.
And so that community
building still has to go on.
MELANIE WARRICK: And let
me end on this point.
If people are interested
in getting involved,
you know, whether
it's participating
in the actual
conference, whether it's
providing resources,
you know, whatever it
is, how do they get in touch?
Who do they get in touch with?
VUKOSI MARIVATE:
At the moment, I
think on the website we've
set up a link to try and get
as much information about
researchers, practitioners,
and professionals on the
continent in machine learning
in AI and data science.
So you can go and actually
sign up and submit a form.
We're trying to keep track.
We have a mailing list that
people can sign up for.
They can send messages
through that in terms
of for the community that's
connected to the Indaba
and beyond.
That's the ambition there.
And through the website
there is a contact.
And if you send
an email to that,
they will then get in
touch with us directly.
We all man-- all the organizers
actually man the email,
so somebody will
respond to you quickly
in terms of what you can do.
So the website is like
the lightning rod,
and you'll get all
this information there.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Vukosi, Yasin, Willie, thank
you all for joining me today.
I really appreciate it.
VUKOSI MARIVATE:
Thanks, Melanie.
WILLIE BRINK: Thank you.
YASIN MUSA AYAMI: Thank you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Today, I'm very
happy that Andrea Bohmert is
here with us.
And I have special guest co-host
with me, Nyalleng Moorosi.
Who I know she's
looking at my notes,
because I wrote down her
name and I didn't write down
the right spelling, but I
wrote it so I can read it.
Anyways, thank you
both for being here.
ANDREA BOHMERT: Well, thank
you very much for having us.
MELANIE WARRICK: You're
here because we're
at Deep Learning Indaba.
And you are here to
give us a perspective
from the VC perspective,
in Africa in particular.
Can you tell us a little bit
about you and your background?
ANDREA BOHMERT:
Sure, absolutely.
So as you can hear
from my accent,
I'm not originally
from South Africa.
I'm from Germany.
After finishing university
there, I came to South Africa
for an internship
and kind of stayed.
So that's now 20
something years ago.
So I've spent the my
professional life actually
all in South Africa,
first few years working
for a big corporate and
now, since 12 years,
actually in the venture
capital investment space
here in South Africa.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
Well, so what has the Deep
Learning Indaba conference
been like for you so far?
ANDREA BOHMERT: This
week was actually
a very, very interesting week.
I was unfortunately only able
to be here for the first day,
for the opening day.
Because at the same
time in Cape Town
we have three other
conferences kind of happening.
So I'm actually very,
very excited to be here.
I must say, so far I've
been very, very impressed
with a few things.
First of all, the sheer
quantity of people.
The whole diversity, the
fact that there are people,
I think, from 33 countries here.
And very honestly, I
was quite impressed
by the number of females.
Normally one kind of
thinks data science,
that this is still a very,
very heavily male dominated.
And I was very
positively surprised.
Quite a few women
actually are here.
And I love the communication,
the level of communication.
I thought that data
scientists are introverts.
Apparently they're not.
They actually talk.
MELANIE WARRICK:
We are introverts.
NYALLENG MOOROSI: Some.
MELANIE WARRICK: Some of us are.
NYALLENG MOOROSI: Yeah, some.
I actually think we might
have a mix of some extroverts
and introverts.
But I think we
work well together.
ANDREA BOHMERT: I thought
everybody would just
stand there looking
down being very quiet.
NYALLENG MOOROSI: All geeky.
ANDREA BOHMERT:
And I walked around
and everybody was chatting,
so I think that's amazing.
That's great.
MELANIE WARRICK:
My understanding
is that you are
one of the biggest
investors in AI in Africa.
Is that statement correct?
ANDREA BOHMERT: Well, so
let's put it like this.
I think we are one of
the oldest VC funds here.
And yes, we have always
done tech investments,
and we have done an
investment in a AI company.
I think it's quite
interesting, because not
many African investors have so
far invested in AI or machine
learning kind of companies.
A number of international have.
If I want to talk about I'll be
one of the very few Africans,
like South African
investors, who
have invested in a AI company.
Then yes, absolutely.
NYALLENG MOOROSI: You know,
you mentioned something
about the number of
women that you seen here.
How is the number
of women in the VC,
especially in the area of
investing in AI in Africa?
Are you just the one data point?
ANDREA BOHMERT: Yeah.
Yes.
No, I think I'm not
the one data point.
But I think that--
I can actually not
talk about the African.
I have to refer to
the South African.
But I think in South Africa
there are maybe three, four
female investment partners.
Yes, it's a very heavily
male dominated world.
But it is [INAUDIBLE]
and we are working on it.
MELANIE WARRICK: From
what you're saying,
why is it that not as many
VCs in the African continent
are doing investments
in AI in Africa?
ANDREA BOHMERT: I
think first of all,
you should invest in
things that you understand.
And before you ask me
whether I understand AI,
that's a different story.
But I think a lot of people
are a little bit scared
because, AI is kind of used
in close to every pitch.
There's a lot of hype about it.
There's buzzword bingo
absolutely around.
If I look at the business plans
that come across my table,
I would say every second
has got a word like AI or ML
somewhere in the business
plan, which doesn't mean
that they're really doing it.
MELANIE WARRICK: True.
ANDREA BOHMERT: And I
think a lot of investors
are scared to fall for the hype.
Because the moment
of course the company
is really an AI company, they
ask for much higher valuations.
So that's why a
lot of businesses
are now trying to get to go
and sneak those words in,
so they employ one data
scientist who maybe actually
just does a bit of very
advanced Excel modeling,
and they call it
now, we're doing AI.
And I think a lot of
investors are still
quite nervous to understand,
is this now a company
that really knows what
they're talking about?
Is this now really a company
that applies deep algorithms
and understands
what they're doing?
Or is it just one of
those hype companies?
And I think that's one of
the big reasons for it.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, what does
AI mean to you as an investor?
ANDREA BOHMERT: For me, it
means that you're not just
slicing and dicing
existing kind of data.
But actually that
you can kind of
go and start using this data,
teach it to kind of go and get
information out of
itself and just taking it
to the next level to
come up with insights
that were previously not there.
And this is far more than just
slicing and dicing with data.
It is taking it
to the next level.
And for that you need to have
some very, very ingrained
understanding and skills.
And a lot of companies
simply do not have them.
But they use the
buzzword without having
the capabilities, without
actually applying it in the way
that it kind of should happen.
I think that's where one of
the big, big differences are.
NYALLENG MOOROSI:
Can you just walk
us a little bit on the
history of your company
and how you ended up here
in this fairly unique space?
ANDREA BOHMERT: In
terms of in South Africa
or in the Deep Learning
Indaba, or in terms of?
NYALLENG MOOROSI: No, not
the Deep Learning Indaba.
As a VC.
ANDREA BOHMERT: As a VC.
NYALLENG MOOROSI: In the idea
of the history of a VC company.
ANDREA BOHMERT: Sure.
How I got into VC is
actually quite a funny story,
but might be kind of too long.
I just wanted to be a VC and
there was no venture capital,
so I managed to go and raise
a fund from a high net worth
individual, the
previous founder of SAP.
And that's how I
kind of got into VC.
Our fund itself is now
about 12 years old,
and it's quite interesting.
In South Africa, we've got
a very, very established--
actually, in Africa,
private equity industry.
Everybody wants to
invest in infrastructure.
But when it comes to
investing in technology,
there's actually very little.
A lot of people still say
that technology is too risky,
early stage technology
is too risky,
and early stage
technology in Africa
is definitely far too risky.
So therefore, if you're
going to go and look at it,
there is not much institutional
money, like in the US
or in the world.
The VCs are founded
by institutions.
In Africa, most of
them are actually
founded by high net
worth individuals who
are passionate about there's
enough to put certain money
kind of into it.
The problem is that
most of those funds
are relatively small.
So if you have a $20 million
fund in Africa, South Africa,
this is a huge fund.
Internationally, of
course, that means nothing.
So one of the things
that is really,
how to kind of go
and start making
the right investments that
don't need $10, $15 million,
but actually need $2, $3
million and really kind
of go and take them.
And we as a fund have done this
now for the last few years.
We have just closed
our first fund,
where we had seven investments.
Of the seven investments,
we had four exits
to global kind of
Fortune 500 companies.
We are one of the few funds
who can really go and say
that we have closed a
whole investment cycle.
Investing?
Everybody can invest.
The question is, can you
make returns out of it?
And can you make
returns out of it
that not just make you
as an investor happy,
but make actually the
entrepreneurs and their teams
happy as well?
Because it is a
long-term journey.
In venture capital investment,
you can't be short-term greedy.
You have to be long-term greedy.
It is a long, long time when you
have to kind of go in and work
together with companies.
And yeah, we've done this.
We've closed our first fund
very, very successfully
on a high return.
And now we are busy
investing the second fund.
And yeah, I'm very, very excited
to go and see how AI and ML
and how companies who are really
solving African problems using
this kind of new insight and new
knowledge that actually exist,
how we can go make some cool
investments in that space.
MELANIE WARRICK: A couple
different questions are
coming to my mind right now.
But you know, one of
the things in particular
that I know we talked about
briefly before was, how
does this compare--
startups that you're
investing in--
compare to those that
you've seen out of, like,
Silicon Valley, for example?
What does that look like?
ANDREA BOHMERT: So if you think
about it, as I just mentioned,
our funds are relatively small.
So if I can only go and
put $2 or $3 million
into a company, the Silicon
Valley counterparts,
they get $10
million, $15 million.
Sure, we have a slight cost
advantage here in South Africa,
but that only applies while we
are busy here in South Africa.
So the moment you
want to kind of go
into business international,
we still are traveling,
everything still becomes
US dollar based and so on.
So I think the big point is,
because our funds are smaller,
therefore the amount
per company is smaller,
our companies have to
become real businesses.
That's an advantage
and a disadvantage.
So we cannot go and take a
company that can go and be not
profitable for the
next five years,
who can just get and employ,
employ, employ people,
maybe just go and be very,
very academic and come up with
amazing results but don't
actually have a real underlying
business.
In Africa, in South
Africa, our businesses
have to become very,
very quickly businesses
that are making a profit,
because there is not
enough money that you can go
and pump into them all the time.
So therefore, there is a
slightly different mindset.
If we compare the
companies that we
invest in to their
competitors in the US,
for example, then
we quite often see
that they have sometimes
even bigger teams.
They don't have case studies.
They don't work on
return of investment.
They do a lot of consulting
work but actually
are not really worried
about, are we profitable?
Are we making money?
It's because there's not this
kind of pressure on them,
because their investors will
just fund it and fund it.
In our case we tell them, sorry,
you've got $2, $3 million,
you have to make it work.
At the end of that, you
need to be profitable.
So our businesses
really, their focus
is wide because they have
to employ salespeople.
They have to employ
marketing people.
It's not just about the science.
It's actually about
building a real business.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That makes sense.
NYALLENG MOOROSI: Mhm.
I think one of the things
that is always raised,
especially when you get to
the space of entrepreneurship
and obviously funding
entrepreneurs in Africa
is that maybe the market or
the environment is not ready.
I can see you maybe nod?
Yes, this is exactly what
I would like to hear,
is your opinion of,
what do you think
is there in the environment
that either has enabled you
and your company to
be able to capitalize?
Or what do you think is there in
the market that actually might
inhibit somebody else
coming in with their VC
and investing in Africa?
ANDREA BOHMERT: So I think that
all the various ingredients
of the ecosystem
that is needed for
successful entrepreneurship,
the ingredients are there,
but they're not linked.
They are still
working isolations.
In some areas, in
some ecosystems,
it's working closer together.
In others, it's
definitely not, which
makes it far more difficult.
If you as an investor look
to kind of go and make
investments, if you just wait
for the perfect business plan
to arrive in your email inbox,
it's not going to happen.
So you need to be out there.
You need to kind of
go and understand
that you will find
a rough diamond,
and you know you
have to polish it.
The perfect diamond
is not there.
So you need to know how
to identify rough diamonds
and you need to
understand how to polish.
That's the first thing.
From an entrepreneur
point of view,
I think maybe because we
don't have enough highly
visible success
stories out there,
there's still not enough of
the real amazing potential
entrepreneurs that
are actually deciding
to become entrepreneurs.
It's still quite
tempting to actually join
some of the big corporates
who of course are paying
much, much better salaries.
And well, then life
is far more secure.
And it's not that obvious of
how to really go and do it.
I think our academic
institutions, and even
our schools, are also not
preparing students early enough
to also think business.
I think we have a lot
of great specialists.
But if you want to
be an entrepreneur,
you also need to
be a generalist.
You need to understand
how to manage people.
a bit of finance.
You need to understand a
bit of sales and marketing.
So if you are purely a
specialist in a very narrow
area, it's quite difficult
to go and run a business
where you have to be
a generalist as well.
And it's also trying
to kind of go and find
the right diverse team,
right from the beginning.
If you have a group
of 10 data scientists,
they might come up with
the most amazing solutions.
But I'm not sure
whether they come up
with an amazing business.
And I think so we
need to go and start
learning that it's different
skills that are required.
How do we as a country,
as a continent,
make sure that entrepreneurs
actually have access
to those skills or have been
taught those kinds of skills?
And then all the other areas
of the ecosystem, the rules,
the regulations, the
access to funding,
all those kinds of things,
access to expertise,
whether it's legal, accounting,
all of those things--
all those things need
to kind of fit together.
And then I think for the
rest I can definitely
say that the
entrepreneurs that I see
are absolutely on par
with what I see globally.
It's the rest that needs
to kind of go and fit.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That was actually
going to be my next
question to you
is that, based on
what you've seen
so far in the
different countries
that you've been to within the
continent, what's going right?
What's working that's
making it a good place
to be investing in AI?
ANDREA BOHMERT: The
passion is there.
The skills are there.
Seed funding is often missing.
The kind of, how to go and get
somebody to actually take this
leap to actually
go and start it.
Not everybody can
afford to not earn
a salary for a year's time.
So how can we kind of
go and close this gap?
Access to market and
understanding how to sell.
I mean, if your potential client
base is a big corporate, well
then a lot of
people, particularly
come straight from university,
they don't know how to do this.
They don't understand how to
kind of go and commercialize
the business.
So where I see the
biggest challenge is not
when it comes to, could they
develop an amazing solution?
People here have a deep
understanding of the problems
that they want to solve.
They can develop the solution.
What's quite often
missing is how do I
take this solution to market?
How do I get to go and
pitch to a big corporate?
How do I go--
what is the right kind
of pricing for it?
So the challenge
is really in the
how do I go and take
a fantastic solution
and build a fantastic
business out of this?
And I think we need to support.
We need to kind of go and come
up with support structures.
Because that is where
things are missing.
And if I then go to
the US, for example,
somehow I think that gets far
more ingrained from early on.
There's different kind of
support structures there.
So that just seems to
be a bit more easier.
Maybe also because their
customer base is far more
used to actually go
and speak to startups,
whereas here our typical
corporates are still
quite reluctant.
It's typical, nobody ever gets
fired for buying dot dot dot.
I mean, people here
are rather going
to go into business
with larger businesses
than to kind of go and give
a start up a real chance.
So I think it's those
kind of things that
quite often make a difference.
NYALLENG MOOROSI: I have
two questions, actually,
that just follow up from there.
And the first question is, what
drives you to do this work?
I can tell right
here that you're
speaking with a lot of passion.
But what drives you to
do it and to do it here?
And then the second one is, what
are like the specific examples
that get you very excited to
be investing in this space?
ANDREA BOHMERT: I
come from Germany.
I could go back to Germany any
day and start doing it there.
But what I love
about this and what
drives me is the fact
that, there are amazing
challenges here, but
you can solve them.
And you can make an impact,
and you can see the impact.
It's in so many different
things, and I just love this.
I love to work
with entrepreneurs,
and sometimes one phone
call can make a difference.
By helping with the
one little insight,
it can make the difference.
It can make a difference
not just to one entrepreneur
but to the whole
team, to everything.
So I love that part.
I love the fact that
here you can still
challenge the status quo.
You can break new grounds.
And I love the fact that success
can stimulate so many people.
And here I see so
many young people
who really want to go and make a
difference and that could also,
with the right skills,
that could go wherever.
But they choose to stay here
and build amazing businesses
from Africa, to go and make a
difference, to be role models.
And I think that's
what the country needs.
And if I can play a
tiny little role there,
I think that's amazing.
That's the fun part.
And I mean, I have
children myself.
Yeah, I think if we want
to kind of go and prepare
the next future for the world
that's lying ahead of us,
well, you need to go and invest
in passionate entrepreneurs.
That's just what I believe.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Any resources you'd
recommend to those
who are trying
to start their own business,
exploring the space?
ANDREA BOHMERT: I
think one of the tools
that a lot of people
absolutely underestimate
is networking,
networking, networking.
If you just go and sit
behind your computer at home
and you don't talk
to anybody else,
you can read as much as you
want to online, and that's fine.
But that's not going to make it.
I think people need to go and
attend conferences like this.
They need to go out and
they need to go and find
the right communities.
But also, push themselves out of
their comfort zones to not just
kind of go with the like
minded, identical people.
They need to kind of go and
find out who else is out there.
So if you are somebody who
is very, very good at data
science, you somehow
need to find somebody
who's good at commercial.
Try to find those people.
Try to find out
who else is there.
I think people need to
kind of go and understand
that people buy
from people, people
invest in people, people
do business with people.
And therefore, we
need to go and build--
the human touch is important.
I mean, you've got to go
and build closer, still
wider networks of different
people who can kind of go
and engage, help each other.
Because then you can build
all together success stories.
So I think it's not so
much about, what do I read
and what I do?
It is about who do I talk to and
how open am I to just hearing
different views?
Because that might just trigger
how to work together with
and how to kind of go and
build long-lasting partnerships
across boundaries, across
countries, across disciplines.
Because I think that's
what's really needed.
That's what makes
the difference.
MELANIE WARRICK: Any
other last bits of advice
that you wanted to
share with our audience?
ANDREA BOHMERT: Just do it.
I mean-- it really is--
MELANIE WARRICK:
Brought to you by?
ANDREA BOHMERT: No, no, no.
[LAUGHTER]
I think that--
MELANIE WARRICK:
Which is not a bad one
to be mentioning
right now, frankly.
ANDREA BOHMERT: I think the
issue is, there's always
a reason not to do it.
If you're going to go and
want to overthink things,
there is always a reason not
to start your own business.
There's always a reason
to go and play it safe.
But you know what?
This is the time.
This is the age.
There are so many
opportunities out there.
I think people should just
take it while they're young.
Just do it.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, Nyalleng,
thank you for helping me.
And Andrea, thank you.
This was really wonderful.
Thank you.
NYALLENG MOOROSI: This
was really good, yeah.
ANDREA BOHMERT: Pleasure.
Thank you for having me.
Thank you.
NYALLENG MOOROSI: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you again,
Yasin, Vukosi, and Andrea for
all coming onto the podcast
to talk to us today.
Really appreciate it.
Now it's time for our
question of the week.
And the question of the week?
Main takeaways from
the conference.
And I'll go ahead and
I'll kick this off.
From the standpoint of what
has been really impressive to
me is to see how
much what I see here
in terms of talking
to the people
I've talked to is
common across the board.
You know, the fears of I don't
know enough, I'm scared--
the imposter syndrome,
which everyone has.
But then still,
the people who are
willing to take the risks,
to go into the space,
has been really impressive.
And what's even more impressive
to me about this conference
is how welcoming and
inclusive people are.
You don't always
see that everywhere.
And this space can
definitely lead to a very,
like, you don't have
enough x, y and z.
Certain people will
have that attitude.
But thankfully, everyone
I've come across here
is just very eager to open
doors, just excited to learn,
and that's really amazing to me.
I'm so glad I was able to come
and see that and experience
that.
And I'm grateful
for you guys making
it so easy for me to be here.
So thank you.
VUKOSI MARIVATE: I think for
me, my key takeaway really
is a question, which
is, where do we go next?
And I think as an organization
and as a community,
we really have to think
very hard about where are we
taking this?
I mean, Africa has such a huge
appetite for machine learning,
for AI.
There is a lot of talent here.
Africa, of course, has
all these challenges
which are very unique globally.
So I think we will
continue to discuss
what is the best way
that we can really
strengthen Africa and really
make the world a better place.
NYALLENG MOOROSI: Yeah,
my takeaway from this
probably is just a
lot of excitement
because what differentiated last
year's Indaba from this year's
Indaba is the leap
that the last year
Indaba had on the audience.
Because this time
around, what has happened
is that people have gone
back and people have
gone to transform their lives.
And my most inspired moment
was during the Maathai Awards.
Obviously, he's one of the
people that is on the podcast,
and I think he is inspiring.
So my takeaway from here
this week is, AI in Africa
is happening.
And AI in Africa
can have impact.
And the impact, we
already see the results.
So there is no real
need for us to doubt.
Believe in the
bigger things that
are proposed as challenges.
Because for as much as
they are challenges,
there are so many
examples now here
that we have seen at
the Indaba of people
that have ignored those
challenges and went forward
and built AI and AI tools
to improve African lives.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
Willie, let me ask you.
Anywhere you're going to be
next other than sleeping soon?
WILLIE BRINK: Yes.
I think for the
immediate future,
I'm just going to go back to my
own lab here at Stellenbosch.
A lot of my students
attended the Indaba,
and I'm sure they were all
really excited and inspired
by everything that
they've experienced.
And I'm looking forward
to just chatting to them
and seeing where can we
take our own research next.
Then, of course, we also
have another machine
learning summer
school in Stellenbosch
happening in January.
And yeah, we have a few
exciting new programs also
in development at Stellenbosch
in machine learning
and artificial intelligence.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
Nyalleng, what about you?
NYALLENG MOOROSI: Yes, I
guess the first thing that
is probably going to happen is
we will probably get to Ghana.
So there will be that move.
And then for the actual
machine learning community,
I will be in
Montreal in December
with the Women in
Machine Learning.
We'll be at NIPS.
I am one of the core organizers
of the Women in Machine
Learning there.
So we're running the workshop.
Yes, and I think
besides that, there's
going to be a month
without Indaba.
And so there will
be a month of sleep.
MELANIE WARRICK: That
sounds like a good month.
Well, all right, so in terms of
the usual with Mark and myself,
we will both be at
Strange Loop next week.
And so you should
come and say hi to us
if you're going to be there.
Outside of that, we'll
share more about where
we're going to be next week.
Thank you both again.
Nyalleng, Willie,
I really appreciate
you both joining
me on the podcast
and helping me
put this together.
Thank you.
NYALLENG MOOROSI: Thank you.
WILLIE BRINK: Thank
you to you, Melanie.
[MUSIC PLAYING]